MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
ALL BELL FOR JUICE BRADFORD
CABALLERO CHIANG DALLY DOG
THERE ALSO GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALEZ WROTE HERTZBERG HILL
WEST SO TANTO. JACKSON JONES
LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONNING
MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN PAN
PORTANTINO ROUGH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN I'M BURKE WHITE COLOR
SCHEME WIENER WILK. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR
GUESTS BE ON THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LET IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WILL BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG BY SENATOR GONZALEZ. LET
US BE CENTERED IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. ON THIS VALENTINE'S
DAY I OFFER THE FOLLOWING POEM
BY ROOMY IT'S CALLED
RELATIONSHIP BOOSTER. YOU CAN
LET ME KNOW IF IT WORKS. HERE
IS A RELATIONSHIP BOOSTER THAT
IS GUARANTEED TO WORK. EVERY
TIME YOUR SPOUSE OR SIGNIFICANT
OTHER SAYS SOMETHING STUPID.
MAKE YOUR EYES LIGHT UP AS IF
YOU HAD JUST HEARD SOMETHING
BRILLIANT. SO GRACIOUS GOD
SOURCE OF ALL LOVE WE TRUST
THOSE YOUR EYES LIGHT UP AT THE
VERY THOUGHT OF EACH ONE OF US
A MAN. PLEASE JOIN ME. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF. OR.
AND ASIAN CROWD INDIVISIBLE
WITH. FOR ALL. THE WAY. TO GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS HAPPY
VALENTINE'S DAY LET US ALWAYS
REMEMBER THAT LOVE ALWAYS WINS.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR FEBRUARY
TENTH THROUGH THE FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY WILL BE APPROVED
AS CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE
CLERK. INTRODUCTION OF FIRST
BILL FIRST READING AND BILLS
WILL BE DEEMED READ WE'LL MOVE
ON TO THE CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE SENATE THIRD READING
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS TODAY WE'LL
START WITH ITEM ELEVEN. ARE
EXCUSE ME ITEM EIGHT SENATOR
JACKSON ARE YOU PREPARED. IF I
CAN ASK THOSE IN FRONT OF
SENATOR JACKSON'S DESK TO
DISPERSE THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTY
ONE BY SENATOR JACKSON'S
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA COURT
REPORTING AND CAPTIONING WEEK
SENATE JACKSON THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES. GOOD
MORNING HAPPY VALENTINE'S DAY
IT'S ACTUALLY A FITTING DAY
THAT WE HONOR OUR COURT
REPORTERS THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF WHOM ARE WOMEN
FREQUENTLY WOMEN WHO ARE EITHER
THE SOLE BREADWINNER THE
PRIMARY BREADWINNER OF THEIR
FAMILIES THIS IS A PROFESSION.
THAT ALLOWS THEM SOME
FLEXIBILITY- SO THAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO WORK ONCE THE LIGHTS
ROUTE THE KIDS WERE IN BED
HOPEFULLY ASLEEP- BUT IT'S A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FUNCTION
FOR OUR COURTS AS WELL. AND
THEY ARE OFTEN OVERLOOKED AND
CLEARLY UNDERAPPRECIATED. AS
PART OF THE LEGAL PROFESSION IT
IS NO EXAGGERATION TO SAY
THOUGH THAT WITHOUT THEM THE
FAIR EFFECTIVE AND IMPARTIAL
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE WOULD
BE IMPOSSIBLE. JUSTICE CAN
OFTEN. FOR ALL IF YOU WILL OR
TURN ON THE UTTERANCE OF A
SINGLE WORD. S. EVERY LITIGATOR
WORTH HER SALT- IN A FEW OF
THEM WERE WORTH HIS SALT. WE'LL
TELL YOU COURT REPORTERS CHOU'S
DON'T TAKE DICTATION THEY
MANAGE A DEPOSITION OR
INTERVENE IN A COURT HEARING TO
ENSURE THE ACCURACY AND THE
FAITHFULNESS OF A RECORD. THEY
HAVE TO STUDY TECHNICAL JARGON
FROM PHYSICS TO MEDICINE TO
CHEMISTRY TO SCIENCE THEY HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO READ PATENTS AND
PLEADINGS TO ENSURE THEY GET
DOWN EXACTLY THE RIGHT WORD
BASED ON CONTEXT AND MEANING.
THEY ORGANIZED DISCUSSIONS AND
CALL THE QUEEN'S TO ENSURE
READABILITY AND USEFULNESS THEY
ARE THE KEY TO AN ACCURATE
RECORDS SO THAT JUSTICE CAN BE
SERVED. THEY ARE GUARDIANS FOR
THE RECORD THEY INSURANCE
DEVELOPED NEW TRULY AND FAIRLY
AS FAIRLY AS POSSIBLE SO PLEASE
JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING OUR
COURT REPORTERS AND CAPTION
EARNERS. BY VOTING I FOR S. C.
R. EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON THUNDER GONZALEZ. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA BARBARA FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I TO ALSO WANT TO
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM
TODAY THERE ARE MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN COURT
REPORTERS EMPLOYED BY THE COURT
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND AS WE
KNOW IT IS A VERY FEMALE
DOMINATED PREVENT A PROFESSION
THIS JOB HAS BEEN ONE THAT
AFFORDS WOMEN IN THE PROFESSION
THE ABILITY TO HAVE A STABLE
INCOME AND EARNED ENOUGH.
SUPPORT FOR THEIR FAMILY AND
THEIR CHILDREN AS WELL AS
ADVANCING THEIR CAREERS AND
EDUCATION AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION AND I
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO ENSURE
THAT COURT REPORTERS IN MY
COMMUNITY AND ALL OR CALIFORNIA
HAVE THE PROPER RESOURCES WITH
CONTINUED AND EDUCATION AND FOR
COMPENSATION ARE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE ABOUT.
THANK YOU SENATOR GONZALEZ
SENATOR MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF. S. C. R. EIGHTY ONE
MANY COURT REPORTERS ARE-
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS WHO
WORK OUT OF THEIR HOMES AS WAS
NOTED- THEIR JOBS CAN BE DONE
REMOTELY AFTER THE KIDS ARE
ASLEEP. SO A STENOGRAPHIC I
LOOKED UP KHAN'S THIRTY NINE
HUNDRED AND NINETY FIVE
DOLLARS. BUT A EMPLOYEE CANNOT.
DEDUCT THE UNREIMBURSED
BUSINESS EXPENSES SO PER FOR
OUR COURT REPORTERS I HOPE THIS
YEAR WE CAN FIND UP BALANCER
RESOLUTION TO THEIR INCOME TAX
SITUATION AS WE CONTINUE TO
DEBATE COMMON LAW EMPLOYEE
VERSES INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SENATOR MORLOCKS
UNDERMINING. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I ALSO WANT TO STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION AND
RECOGNITION ON STENOGRAPHER
STAY I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
A STENOGRAPHER WHO WORKS WITH
US IN SENATE RULES COMMITTEE I
KNOW LE BLANC WHO IS PRESENT AT
EVERY RULES COMMITTEE AND IT
DOES THIS AMAZING JOB OF
CAPTURING. SOMETIMES FAST
TALKING. PEOPLE THAT DON'T
EXPRESS THEMSELVES CLEARLY
ALWAYS AND SHE- KEEPS PACE IN
CAPTURES EVERY STEP- JUST A
SHOUT OUT TO OUR IN HOUSE
STENOGRAPHER MINA LE BLANC
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
MONEY WE DO APPRECIATE AINA
MEMBERS ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE THING IN HEARING MEN
CENTER JACKSON WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU A AND I
AM REMINDED THE CLOSER YOU GET
TO THE JUSTICE SYSTEM THE MORE
YOU APPRECIATE. THE GREAT WORK
THAT THESE PEOPLE DO AND
CERTAINLY HERE IN ORDER TO
CREATE AN ACCURATE RECORD WE
CAN ARGUE ABOUT INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR VERSUS EMPLOYEE AT
SOME OTHER TIME TODAY I BELIEVE
IS THE TIME THAT WE SHOULD
CELEBRATE THIS EXTRAORDINARY
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
DEDICATED TO MAKING SURE THAT
JUSTICE IS SERVED THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATE JACKSON
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL HI
GORGEOUS HI BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO HI CHIANG HI DALY HI
DODD. HI THERE ALSO HI GALGIANI
HI GLAZER HI GONZALEZ. HI GROVE
HI HERTZBERG HI HILL. HI WES
SO. HIGH TADO HI JACKSON I
JONES. LEYVA HI HI REQUIRE HI
MITCHELL. MONNING HI MORE LOCK
HIGH MORALE. NIELSEN HI PAN
YEAH HI PORTANTINO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO. BY SKINNER. STERN HI
NUMBER ALL RIGHT HI WHY BECAUSE
THE- HI WIENER HI WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN THIRTY FOUR HI BASS.
JONES. MITCHELL MORALE. SKINNER.
FIVE THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN SENATOR RUBIO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE TO TEEN
DATING VIOLENCE AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION MONTH CENTER RUBIO
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
PRESIDENT MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT SR SEVENTY
FIVE WHICH IS A WOMAN'S CAUCUS
RESOLUTION. THE PROCLAIMS
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY S. TEEN
DATING VIOLENCE AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION MONTH I ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TWO AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE FOR THEIR CONTINUOUS
COLLABORATION HIGHLIGHTING
THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES OF
DATING VIOLENCE WHICH AFFECTS
PEOPLE OF ALL BACKGROUNDS AND
FAX TO DISCUSS STATISTICS SHOW
THAT EACH YEAR AN ESTIMATED ONE
IN TEN HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT. IS
PHYSICALLY HURT ON PURPOSE BUT
EIGHT BY A PARTNER IN ADDITION
ONE IN ELEVEN FEMALE TEENS ONE
IN FIFTEEN MALE TEENS AND
TWENTY NINETEEN REPORTED
EXPERIENCING PHYSICAL VIOLENCE.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE AND MUST
CHANGE. AS A PERSONAL NOTE I WE
USED TO BE NICE TO TEACH
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL LEVEL AND
WHAT I THINK PARENTS SOMETIMES
ARE REALIZE AND SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE HERE SAYS. I
WAS A FOURTH GRADE TEACHER AND
IN FOURTH GRADE I WOULD SEE. MY
EIGHTY NINE YEAR OLDS PUSHING
EACH OTHER YELLING AT EACH
OTHER. AND IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND THAT AT
THAT AGE THEY'RE ALREADY
PICKING UP HABITS THAT WE WANT
TO CHANGE. I WOULD LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE PARENTS TO ASK THEIR
CHILDREN. AT THEY'VE EVER EVER
BEING YELLED AT PUSHED
MANIPULATED. I USED TO SEE IT
ALL THE TIME. AND IT'S A CYCLE
THAT WE HAVE TO TRY AND BREAK
EARLY ON. IT WILL ONLY CONTINUE
AND GET WORSE SO I ENCOURAGE
ALL OF YOU HERE. TO ENCOURAGE
YOUR CONSTITUENTS TO ALSO- TO
ASK THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT ONLY
THEY ARE TEENAGERS BUT THEY'RE
YOUNG CHILDREN AS WELL. WE HAVE
A MORE ON CIVIC OBLIGATION TO
CHANGE THIS AND WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO EMPOWER
YOUTH AND PREVENT SEXUAL AND
DATING VIOLENCE FROM HAPPENING.
THIS INCLUDES UP LIFTING THOSE
WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED VIOLENCE
SO THAT THEY MAY HEAL AND MOVE
FORWARD. WE MUST CONTINUE TO
ENCOURAGE ARGUED. SOME PRACTICE
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THEIR PARTNERS. AND IT'S NEVER
OKAY. TO BE TOLD WHO TO HANG
OUT WITH. IT'S NEVER OKAY. FOR
YOUR PHONE TO BE TAKEN AWAY
IT'S NEVER OKAY TO TELL YOU IF
YOU CAN SEE YOUR FAMILY. SO I
ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO MEMBER
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE I CITY FOR
KNOWS ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR. DOES ANYONE HAVE
ANYTHING THEY WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE REMOVED BEFORE WE VOTE ON
THIS SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR.
OKAY MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE FORTY ONE
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE EYES
THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED WE'RE NOW
RETURNING TO RESOLUTIONS- RENT
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS IS
THE APPROPRIATE TIME FOR A
JOURNEY MEMORIES. SENATOR PAM.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
SENATORS- TODAY AT RICE
INTERNAL MEMORY OF PASTOR A
TASKER HOLLAND SENIOR. PASTOR
HOLLINS EARNED DEGREES AT THE
SECOND A CITY COLLEGE AND FROM
THE SCHOOL OF BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION AT CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SACRAMENTO. HE
MARRIED HIS WIFE JULIE
HOLLAND'S IN NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN AND THEY'VE HAD THREE
DAUGHTERS AND ONE SON IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX ELDER
SISTER HOLLIS PURCHASING
REHABILITATED AND REMODEL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY NINE
BROADWAY TO BECOME. ALL NATIONS
CHURCH IN THE HEART OF THE OAK
PARK COMMUNITY. WITH THE HELP
OF MEMBERSHIP AND FRIENDS. TWO
YEARS LATER NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT ALL NATIONS CHURCH WAS
PAID IN FULL IN A MORTGAGE
BERNIE CEREMONY WAS HELD. AS
ENVISIONED AND DIRECTED BY
PASTOR HOLLINS ALL NATIONS
CHURCH DEVELOPED AND
IMPLEMENTED VARIOUS PROGRAMS TO
SERVE THE MEMBERSHIP AND THE
OAK PARK COMMUNITY. THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE INCLUDED A WEEKLY
FOOD BANK DANIEL HOME BUYER
SEMINAR VARIOUS FINANCIAL
CLASSES KILL IN PRISON OUT
REACH PROGRAMS YEARLY PROSTATE
BREAST CANCER SEMINARS COMPUTER
AN INTERNET TRAINING CLASSES
STUDENTS STUDY AND TUTORING
PROGRAMS AND SUMMER YOUTH
PROGRAMS FOR AT RISK YOUTH. IN
THE A VERY IMPORTANT AND
CRITICAL PART OF THIS COMMUNITY.
PASTOR HOLLINS WITH A STRONG
COMMITTEE LEADER WHO BE GREATLY
MISSED HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE JULIA HOLLAND'S. SON A
TASKER HOLLINS JUNIOR DAUGHTERS
JUDITH HOLLINS GILROY DIANNE
HOLLINS GUNNING NANCY CRAWLEY
AND FOUR GRANDCHILDREN. PLEASE
JOIN ME AND ADJOURNING AND HIS
MEMORY THANK YOU THE USER PAN
PLEASE BE SURE TO BRING HIS
NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. SENATOR
HILL. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES IT IS WITH
SADNESS THAT I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF JAMES P. FOX A
LIFELONG RESIDENT OF SAN MATEO
COUNTY. WHO SERVED AS THE
COUNTY'S DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS JIM WAS
HIGHLY RESPECTED IN HIS
PROFESSION AND IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND HE WAS BELOVED. PERHAPS IT
MAY SEEM RARE THAT THE TOP
PROSECUTOR FOR A COUNTY IS A
BELOVED INDIVIDUAL BUT ANYONE
WHO KNEW HIM KNOWS THIS WAS
TRUE. THAT'S BECAUSE JIM WAS
DEVOTED NOT ONLY TO LAW AND
ORDER. HE ALSO LOVE JUSTICE AND
FAIRNESS. HIM DEDICATED A
LIFETIME TO THEIR PURSUIT ANY
UNDERSTOOD THAT UPHOLDING
JUSTICE AND FAIRNESS SOMETIMES
MEANT. THAT YOU WOULD STAND
ALONE. A QUARTER CENTURY AGO HE
WAS THE ONLY ELECTED DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN OUR STATE. TO
OPPOSE THE NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
IN AKRON OF THE THREE STRIKES
LAW. MANY CALLED HIM
COURAGEOUS. BUT IT WAS NOT A
SURPRISING MOVE BY A MAN WHO
ONCE SAID IT IS IMPORTANT TO DO
THE RIGHT THING. FOR THE RIGHT
REASONS A NATIVE OF HALF MOON
BAY JIM THAT DECIDED WHEN HE
WAS ONLY EIGHT. TO MAKE LAW HIS
CAREER HE GRADUATED GRADUATED
FROM SERRA HIGH SCHOOL ON THE
PENINSULA AND WORKED HIS WAY
THROUGH COLLEGE BY TAKING OUR
JOBS. JIM EARNED HIS COLLEGE
AND LAW DEGREE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
WHEN HE GOT HIS FIRST JOB AS A
DEPUTY. DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR
SAN MATEO COUNTY HE ALSO SPENT
SOME TIME IN PRIVATE PRACTICE
IN SERVICE HALF MON BAY CITY
ATTORNEY. HE RAN FOR COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO AND ONE. ANYONE
AGAIN AND ONE AGAIN AND AGAIN
SERVING A TOTAL OF SEVEN TERMS.
JIM ALSO HELD SEVERAL
LEADERSHIP ROLES ON LOCAL STATE
AND NATIONAL LEVELS INCLUDING
THE CALIFORNIA AND NATIONAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE BAR
ALL THE WHILE. HE WAS JUST AS
MUCH A MAN OF THE LAW AS HE WAS
A MAN OF IN FOR HIS FAMILY. YOU
TREASURE THE TIME HE SPENT WITH
HIS WIFE BONNIE THEIR CHILDREN
CHRISTINE TIM AND BRIAN THEIR
SPOUSES AND HIS GRANDCHILDREN.
JIM PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY
NINTH HE WAS SEVENTY FIVE. IN
ADDITION TO HIS WIFE CHILDREN
AND THEIR FAMILIES JIM IS
SURVIVED BY HIS BROTHER MICHAEL
HE ALSO IS REMAIN REMEMBERED BY
COLLEAGUES FRIENDS AND
GENERATIONS OF SERRA AND USF
STUDENTS. WILL BE INSPIRED IN
HIS VISITS AND TALK TO THE
CAMPUSES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
HONORING CHANGE P. FOX BY
TURNING IN HIS MEMORY THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER HELP PUT
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FOR. AS
WE- NOT SO GONZALEZ. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- I RISE TODAY
IN TWO ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
JEAN LEINSTER HE WAS BORN APRIL
SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN TWENTY TWO
IN SAINT LOUIS WHERE HIS
PARENTS MOVED TWO DECADES PRIOR
TO ESCAPE THE PER THE- EASTERN
EUROPE- ISSUES JEAN PASSED AWAY
AT NINETEEN I'M SORRY AT NINETY
SIX H. NINETY SEVEN FEBRUARY
SECOND TWENTY TWENTY. GENE WAS
A LEGENDARY LONG BEACH CIVIL
RIGHTS LEADER WHO ADVOCATED FOR
EQUALITY INCLUSION AND
DIVERSITY HE MADE A HUGE IMPACT
IN OUR CITY ACTIVELY FIGHTING
AGAINST RACISM DISCRIMINATION
AND BIGOTRY PRIOR TO HIS TIME
IN LONG BEACH GENE SERVED IN
THE U. S. ARMY DURING WORLD WAR
TWO. BECAUSE OF HIS POOR
EYESIGHT JEAN ACTUALLY MEMORIZE
THE EYE CHART TO MAKE SURE HE
WAS ACCEPTED HE SPENT THREE
YEARS IN THE COMBAT ENGINEERS
IN CALGARY RECONNAISSANCE
MOSTLY OVERSEAS INCLUDING
DURING THE NORMANDY INVASION.
HE LATER MOVED TO LONG BEACH
WHERE HE BOUGHT A WOMAN'S
CLOTHING STORE ON PINE AVENUE
INTO DOWNTOWN LONG BEACH HE
MARRIED HIS WIFE IN ON
SEPTEMBER SECOND NINETEEN FIFTY
ONE. AND WITH HIS BROTHER
GORDON THE BILL THEIR FIRST
STORE INTO A SUCCESSFUL CHAIN
OF TWENTY SIX STORES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND
STARTED GETTING INVOLVED IN
COMMUNITY AFFAIRS AS A
VOLUNTEER AFTER SELLING HIS
BUSINESS FOR MORE THAN FORTY
YEARS HE BEGAN A SECOND CAREER
AS A COMMUNITY LEADER FIGHTING
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS HE JOINED THE
NATIONAL CONFERENCE OF
CHRISTIANS AND JEWS WHICH
EVENTUALLY BECAME THE
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE FOR
EQUALITY AND JUSTICE CCJ. HE
WAS NO STRANGER TO
DISCRIMINATION AND OFTEN TOLD A
STORY THAT HE COULD NOT RENT
APARTMENTS IN LONG BEACH SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF HIS FAITH. THIS
INSPIRED HIM TO CONTINUE
FIGHTING FOR EQUALITY AND
RIGHTS FOR ALL HE FOUNDED THE
INTERNATIONAL I'M SORRY THE
INTERFAITH INTERCULTURAL
PRACTICE OF THE CCJ THIRTY
YEARS AGO AND HELP TO FILL
THEIR MISSION TO FIGHT BIGOTRY
PREJUDICE DISCRIMINATION ANY
QUALITY HE WILL SORELY BE
MISSED HERE IN LONG BEACH AND
ACROSS THE STATE HE IS SURVIVED
BY ANALYSTS INNER. HIS WIFE OF
SIXTY EIGHT YEARS BROTHER
GORDON SONS ALAN AND JAY
GRANDSON DAVID NEPHEW JOEL AND-
THEIR TRIP CHILDREN ATTY SADIE
AND MAISY ANNE'S JULIE. I YOU
SORELY BE MISSED AND THINK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU SIR EXHALL
PLEASE BRING NAME FOR SO HE BE
PROP MORE MORE. SENATOR JACKSON.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES ARE I RISE TO
COMMEMORATE THE EXTRAORDINARY
LIFE OF PART TIME. A SANTA
BARBARA RESIDENT AND GREAT
MOVIE. I CON KIRK DOUGLAS. OF
KIRK LIVED A FIN FANTASTICALLY
LONG AND MEANINGFUL LIFE HE
DIED RECENTLY AT THE AGE OF A
HUNDRED AND THREE. OF MOST IF
YOU WERE HERE WILL. REMEMBER
KIRK DOUGLAS IS THE FATHER OF
MICHAEL DOUGLAS BUT ACTUALLY
KIRK DOUGLAS WAS AN
EXTRAORDINARY STAR IN HIS OWN
RIGHT IN FACT ONE OF THE LAST
OF THE LEGEND OF LEADING
HOLLYWOOD MEN THE BURKE
LANCASTER'S THE GREGORY PECK'S-
IN SO MANY OTHERS HE WAS THE
LAST. TO SURVIVE THAT ERA OF
THE GREAT HOLLYWOOD STAR- HE
WAS BORN A VERY VERY POOR- IN A
VERY VERY POOR JEWISH FAMILY IN
NEW AMSTERDAM NEW YORK- HE
WORKED IN OVER FORTY DIFFERENT
JOBS BY THE TIME HE HAD
FINISHED COLLEGE HE WENT INTO
THE MILITARY AND SERVED. WAS
INJURED CAME TO HOLLYWOOD AND
FOUND HIS PLACE AND WAS A AN
ACTOR OF COMPELLING CHARISMA OF
FOR HIS DAY KNOWN FOR THAT
DIMPLE IN HIS CHIN. I KNOWN FOR
SOME EXTRAORDINARY FILMS HE
MADE WHERE HE PLAYED HEROES AND
OF THE BAD GUY BUT ALWAYS WITH
A CERTAIN COMPELLING- QUALITY
TO IT THAT MADE HIM AGAIN ONE
OF THE GREAT STARS OF
HOLLYWOOD. HE WAS ALSO A VERY
INDEPENDENT DIE AND HE STARTED
HIS OWN INDEPENDENT FILM
COMPANY AND FROM THAT COMPANY
HE PRODUCED- AND STARRED IN A
FILM CALLED SPARTACUS WHICH IF
YOU HAVEN'T SEEN IT I WOULD
URGE YOU TO DO SO IT WAS ONE OF
THE GREAT FILMS OF ALL TIME WON
THE ACADEMY AWARD IN THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES. HE ALSO IN
THE COURSE OF THAT FILM-
REVEALED TO THE WRITER WAS THE
WRITER WAS A MAN NAMED DALTON
TRUMBO. THIS WAS DURING THE
FIFTIES AND SIXTIES DURING THE
MCCARTHY ERA WHEN THE GREAT
SOME OF THE GREAT WRITERS AND
TALENTS OF HOLLYWOOD WERE
BLACKBALLED BECAUSE THEY WERE
BELIEVED TO BE COMMUNISTS AND
HE ACTUALLY HAD THE COURAGE TO
LET HOLLYWOOD IN THE WORLD KNOW
THAT DALTON TRUMBO HAD WRITTEN
THIS. SCREENPLAY. AND IT WAS
REALLY CREE QUITE A FUROR.
BECAUSE THIS WAS A PERIOD OF
TIME WHEN WE HAD THAT RED SCARE
IN THE UNITED STATES SO IF WE
THINK THE FIFTIES OR AN ERROR
THAT WE WANT TO GO BACK TO- I
SUGGEST THAT WE THINK TWICE
ABOUT THAT. BUT KIRK DOUGLAS
DIDN'T THINK TWICE ABOUT IT HE
WAS OUT THERE HE WAS A MAN OF
EXTRAORDINARY PHILANTHROPY HE
AND HIS WIFE ARE CREATED A
NUMBER OF ENTITIES FOR THE
POOR. ARE HE ALSO ONESELF WAS
NOMINATED THREE TIMES FOR
ACADEMY AWARDS AND- FOUNDED TO.
AS I MENTIONED A NUMBER OF
PHILANTHROPIES. HE AND HIS WIFE
AND DOUGLAS CHRIS CREATED THE
CENTER FOR HOMELESS WOMEN- TO
PROVIDE DRUG AND ALCOHOL
ADDICTION TREATMENT AND
SERVICES. PROVIDED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR POOR KIDS
LIKE HE HAD BEEN HIMSELF BUT AS
AN EXAMPLE OF THE GREAT
AMERICAN DREAM. THE YEAR ALL OF
HOLLYWOOD HAS IT HAS NEVER BEEN
KNOWN SINCE I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
US ALL TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF QUITE A STAR. KIRK DOUGLAS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD AS WELL SO HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE FOR A
JOINT IN MEMORY OF DAVID
CARESS. FORMER CITY OF INDUSTRY
MAYOR WHO SERVED FOR ELEVEN
YEARS HE WAS ELECTED INTO
OFFICE IN TWO THOUSAND ONE AND
SERVED UNTIL TWENTY TWELVE WHEN
HE STEPPED DOWN TO HEALTH
RELATED ISSUES. DAVID WAS BORN
AND RAISED IN THE CITY OF
INDUSTRY AND DEDICATED TO
BUILDING UP HIS COMMUNITY AND
BUILDING UP THE EIGHTEEN
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT FOCUSING ON
ALSO JOB CREATION HE WAS AN
ENTREPRENEUR AND DEVOTED
COUNTLESS HOURS TO A VARIETY OF
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING A MONEY BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUB. THAT GABRIEL
FOUNDATION AND HE WAS ALSO A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
INDUSTRY'S SHERIFF'S STATION
YOUTH ACTIVITIES LEAGUE. HE
REALLY CARED ABOUT HIS
COMMUNITY ARE YOU AND
SUPPORTING SERVICE CLUBS DAVID
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE SHIRLEY
AND HIS PRESENCE WILL BE MISSED
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CLOSING ON
HIS BEHALF THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO PLEASE BRING HIS
NAME FORWARD SO HE TOO CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED CENTER
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU AYE MADAM
PRESIDENT AND THAT COLLEAGUES
SAID TODAY I RISE IN HONOR. OF
THE LIFE OF ROBERT GORSKI- MR
GORSKY PASSED AWAY ABOUT TWO
WEEKS AGO- HE WAS BORN IN OHIO.
ON SEPTEMBER TWENTY SIX
NINETEEN FORTY NINE. BOB ROBERT
WAS A LEADER IN THE DISABILITY
RIGHTS ADVOCACY COMMUNITY
IMPROVING ACCESSIBILITY FOR
PASADENA. AND HELPING IT AND
HELPING IMPLEMENT. THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITY ACT
WHICH PASSED IN NINETEEN
NINETY. ACCESSIBILITY WAS A
PERSONAL JOURNEY AND A PASSION
FOR ROBERT BECAUSE WHEN HE WAS
A CHILD HE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
POLIO. WHICH LEFT HIM
WHEELCHAIR BOUND FOR HIS ENTIRE
LIFE. ROBERT JOIN THE CITY OF
PASADENA AS- DISABILITY TEAM IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE HIRED AS
AN ACCESSIBILITY ISSUES
COORDINATOR HE ADVOCATED AND
IMPROVED FOR CURBS CROSSWALKS
BUILDING ENTRANCES. PROVIDED
ACCESSIBLE PARKING SPACES AND
ASSISTIVE LISTENING SERVICES HE
MADE PASADENA MORE
ACCOMMODATING TO ALL BODIES AND
LIVES HE WAS DECADES AHEAD OF
HIS TIME ROBERT WORKED AND
REACHED OUT NOT JUST TO HELP
THE CITY BUT WE'VE ALL BEEN TO
THE ROSE BOWL. HE HELPED MAKE
THE ROSE BOWL ATA ACCESSIBLE AS
WELL AS VOTING BOOTHS IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT EVERYONE HAS
ACCESS TO A VOTING BOOTH
THROUGH ROBERT PASADENA WAS
HONORED IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE.
BY THE NATIONAL COUNCIL ON
DISABILITIES AS ONE OF THE MOST
ACCESSIBLE CITIES IN THE
COUNTRY. MAY WE CONTINUE TO
SERVE IN THE WORDS THAT ROBERT
USED TO USE ALL THE TIME IN
LIBERTY JUSTICE AND ACCESS FOR
ALL MY DEEPEST CONDOLENCES
CONDOLENCES TO THE GORSKI
FAMILY- WE WISH THEM WELL AT
THIS TIME OF GRIEF AND THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES FOR JOINING IN
HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO PLEASE BRING HIS
NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. MEMBERS
IF THERE IS NO FURTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU AND PRESIDENT
I TO MY COLLEAGUES A VERY HAPPY
VALENTINE'S DAY I IT IS EARLY
HOPEFULLY YOU'LL GET HOME TO BE
WITH YOUR FAMILY YOUR LOVED
ONES- WE'LL SEE YOU ON TUESDAY
FIFTH TUESDAY. BECAUSE MONDAY
IS A HOLIDAY SO TUESDAY
FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH AT TWO PM.
THANK YOU MADAM PROTECT THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE WILL RECONVENE TUESDAY AT TO
BE AT TWO PM HAVE A GREAT DAY
MEMBERS.